imagine if you could walk to work each
morning stop at the local coffee shop
and still have time to Pat Winston
imagine if you could talk to your best
friend all day and go to lunch with the
Senior Partners overlooking the bay
believe it or not here at Lincoln's we
have made it possible and we are living
our life beyond numbers founded in 1951
and located in Albany
Western Australia Lincoln's provides an
unprecedented accounting experience due
to the family life bond present amongst
the 40 staff members you can usually
spot us on the weekends exploring the
stunning surroundings Albany has to
offer from the Strawberry Hill Farm to
Middleton Beach's breathtaking views
Albany has it all even a wind farm which
keeps everything running smoothly
much like our support team without them
we would be in the dark behind closed
doors you'll find more than a few teams
like Gary's team who specialize in
succession planning and agriculture gary
is known as a class clown in the office
this is Rob's team Rob is a hardcore
nature lover his team specializes in
pharmacies in the wine industry this is
Craig stone Kraig is our office handyman
his team specializes in the agriculture
and construction industry this is
Brendan's team brendan is our in-house
pilot and can take us all over the state
his team specializes in farming
manufacturing and transport and this
this is Russell's team his team
specializes in business advisory audit
governance and superannuation Russell is
our longest serving partner and loves
adventure we even have our own in-house
bookkeeping team they like to keep
things in
with so many teams we like to celebrate
our accomplishments as one each end of
financial year our five partners come
together to create extraordinary
surprise parties going above and beyond
for each staff member on the day which
over the years has created countless
friendships and endless memories but had
gala dinners murder mysteries mastership
woodstock battle of the bands and
everything in between
it's these events that have truly
brought us together and made us lifelong
friends even those who have left us to
pursue other goals return to Albany to
celebrate at our amazing reunion every
employee since day one was invited to
celebrate Lincoln's no matter how many
faces come and go or how large we grow
here at Lincoln's we will continue
living our life beyond numbers